bion tech and pfizer are proud sponsors
of the oscars
what's up people i'm dave rubin this is
the reuben report direct message and
it's march 28 2022 and boy what a sunday
the [ __ ] slap heard around the world i
was not watching
but i did see it on twitter after my
phone started blowing up with the text
messages the unedited video coming in
from australia and japan of will smith
smacking chris rock oh my god everyone's
freaking out
we're live streaming on rumble youtube
and blaze tv today do me a favor and
subscribe and tap the notification bell
on those things would you we are going
to unpack the smack and really discuss
was it real and did the machine perhaps
need us to be distracted from something
else that happened this weekend because
i don't know if you heard old joe
biden's speech joe the guy pretending to
be president of the united states where
he basically called for a regime change
in russia and then they backtracked on
that one and now everybody's talking
about something else we're also going to
talk a little bit about how hollywood
manipulates us i think we've got a nice
through line for you today and uh
this sort of words are violence thing
and if you joke about people that
apparently now you're allowed to smack
people and beat people and that the
hollywood woke machine is breaking down
right in front of our eyes yet still has
some trickery uh before i get to any of
that guys i want to remind you that
don't burn this country my second book
is coming out on april 12th you can
pre-order it right now at daverubin.com
book sales are going extremely well
we've looked at the numbers and it looks
as if despite their best efforts the new
york times will have to put us on the
list
and then i can make fun of them for
doing just that and of course i'm going
on tour that's right i'll be in orlando
on april 18th i'll be on in west palm
beach april 19th with don trump jr you
may have heard of him on april 20th i'll
be in clearwater florida with benny
johnson april 21st
uh
andrew clavin will be joining me uh in
raleigh north carolina at the raleigh
improv april 22nd the willy wonka of
politics michael malus will be joining
me april 23rd john me park in chicago
april 24th glenn beck from the blaze in
dallas texas april 25th megan mccain in
washington dc april 26th we've got megan
kelly in west nyack new york may 11th
dennis prager who's coming here for
dinner tonight that's right
may 12th larry elder in oxnard
california may 15 san jose california
will announce the guest on that one soon
may 16th the next senator from the great
state of arizona at the tempe improv
blake masters and may 18th in denver
we'll announce the guests on that one
too you can get tickets at daverubin.com
events especially the vip seats selling
out fast so you can get your tickets
right now davereuben.com
slash events we've got a big show for
you today i'm very excited to do the
show i hope you had a good weekend i
hope you didn't really pay attention to
politics i hope you ate some good food i
hope you listen to some good music i
hope you jumped in the pool i hope you
did some gardening whatever makes you
happy people which is why when i got all
these text messages last night have you
seen what's happening at the oscars i
didn't even know that the oscars were on
i had no freaking clue that the oscars
were on i don't know that i've even seen
a movie that was nominated for the
oscars i honestly don't think i could
name one movie that that was nominated i
did see spider-man this weekend which i
want to talk about a little bit later
i'm going to link it to the whole thing
about how bad hollywood has become
but i don't think anyone cares about any
of this stuff and suddenly we sort of
have to talk about it because we do live
in these odd culture wars that leak into
everything else so that's what the show
is all about today i'm fired up i'm
caffeinated i'm ready to go i hope
you're feeling good on this monday and
before i get to any of that guys i want
to talk to you about the stack real
quick you know if the last two years
have taught us anything it's that you
must take control of your own health
it's clear that you simply can't rely on
the government or big pharma to protect
you or your family and that's where
zstack comes in i'm holding a bottle
right now z stack is a specially
formulated immune boosting supplement
that includes zinc quiceridine vitamin c
and vitamin d formulated by dr vlad
zelenko the world renowned doctor that
president trump credited with his
successful early treatment protocol in
his decision to take hcq zstack has been
scientifically formulated as kosher and
gmp certified and produced right here in
the good old u.s of a although mass
mandates are being lifted and vaccine
mandates are no longer enforced in
several states hallelujah viruses are
still out there by taking z-stack daily
you're supercharging your immune system
z-stack is formulated to combat any and
all variants as well as the common cold
and flu i encourage you to start taking
it now ahead of any potential future
variants to prepare your immune system
and go about living your life go to
zsaclife.com
dave today enter the promo code dave and
get a discount off your first order
about zstacklife.com dave promo code
dave okay that's all the promotion i
promise you so the big event of last
night was the oscars and i really before
i play the clip that has been played
bajillion times it's the clip growing
across the world we're going to play the
whole thing but were you watching the
oscars last night does anyone you know
care about the oscars does anyone care
about hollywood anymore but it finds a
way to get us to talk about it again
doesn't it we'll talk about that in just
a moment but in case you're under a rock
and you have not seen this yet
here is chris rock
making a joke and will smith take an
offense
jada i love you g.i jane 2 can't wait to
see it all right
[Applause]
[Music]
it's javazone that was a nice one okay
i'm out here oh richard
oh wow
wow
[Applause]
will smith just smack the [ __ ] out of me
nick's name
dude
yeah it was a gi jane jump keep my
wife's name out
now i'm going to okay
oh i could oh okay
that was a
greatest night in the history of
television okay
okay so there's a lot to unpack with
this thing
first off uh let's just show you the
tweet from cnn about it and let's just
see if you can understand the way they
use words to confuse reality cnn will
smith won his first academy award on
sunday night and offered his apologies
to the academy and others for an earlier
incident in which the actor appeared
to strike presenter chris rock
appeared he appeared
to strike chris rock now what i want to
do is i want to replay it we're going to
replay the video here in the little box
that we've got let's play that thing so
he's making a joke now watch first will
smith laughs at the joke can't wait to
see it all right
there's will smith that's the joke he's
laughing at it now jada pink smith he's
talking about her being bald she has
alopecia i'll get to alopecia
in just a moment but he laughed at the
joke will smith laughed at the joke
she did not laugh and then here you go
he comes up smacks him it sort of looked
like a punch but then it looked
open-headed and then he walks off like
he's a real tough guy really yeah and
chris rock to his credit if we're to
believe that any of this was real chris
rock cleans it up quite nicely okay
we've seen the rest we can we can let it
go and then will smith yells now
i want to mention something that i've
mentioned a couple of times on the show
before uh kayfabe can we throw the
definition of kayfabe up because this is
a word that you really should know and i
think really helps explain so much of
our cultural wars and our political uh
upheaval these days kayfabe
k-a-y-f-a-b-e
in professional wrestling the fact or
convention of presenting staged
performances as genuine or authentic a
masterful job of blending k fabe and
reality so what kfabe is the the word
kayfabe the phrase kayfabe is what
professional wrestling is that when you
go see
hulk hogan wrestle andre the giant or
jake the snake roberts wrestle the macho
man can you see when i watched wrestling
from about 30 years ago i don't know
who's in wrestling anymore that you
watch these things you know that they're
fake we all know they're fake they know
they're fake and yet we're all playing
along and having real emotions believing
that jake the snake roberts is you know
that the snake is actually
putting venom into macho man's arm or
that andre the giant is sitting on hulk
hogan's head and he's gonna asphyxiate
him or whatever it is and we're
screaming and we're watching and we're
demanding more of something we all know
that is fake and i don't know whether
this thing was fake or not but i do know
a couple things and that would include
that the oscar ratings have been
terrible over the last couple years
people are not watching people are not
going to the movie theaters because the
entire system crashed our ability to go
out with each other and be in you know
common spaces together i don't know the
last time i saw like a really good
original movie i have no idea could i
get the names of the of the best films i
bet you i haven't heard a half of them
and maybe and i sincerely doubt i'd seen
any of them can you pull up whatever was
nominated for for best film i don't even
know what will smith won for honestly um
but but because they know no one's
paying attention would you put it above
the machinery of hollywood
to
fabricate something like this that that
chris rock makes a fairly innocuous joke
i mean she's got a shaven head and i'll
talk more about alopecia in a sec as i
said um and that will smith so loses
control he's laughing at the joke at
first that he so lost control of himself
that on an evening where he knows
millions even though it's not as many
millions as it used to be millions of
people are watching that he so lost
control of himself that he walks up on
stage comment he didn't bum rush the
stage right he walks up there smacks the
guy and just sits down no security came
and got him uh nobody you know
apparently during the commercials there
were some pr people saying something to
him um but you know we could also add
like the weird woke element of race to
this so it was black on black violence
which people obviously treat a little
bit differently i suspect that if matt
damon had gotten out of the crowd very
pasty white matt damon had gotten out of
the crowd and smacked chris rock we'd be
there would be riots in the streets uh
you know so there's a whole series of
things like do you put it past the
hollywood machinery that sort of
seemingly is faking everything all the
time in our culture and our politics
that this might have been staged i don't
know does that make me like a complete
conspiracy theorist not only that but
pfizer as we showed you in the cold open
today pfizer sponsored the oscars they
sponsor the left leaning the leftist
machine that is hollywood the uh
the movies that were up for uh best
oscar or best movie of the year king
richard with will smith i have no idea
did not see that never heard of it coda
didn't see that no
belfast
no idea west side story well i know the
original west side story i guess they
brought it back okay uh dune which i saw
i fell asleep i tried to watch it again
i fell asleep both times it was sort of
fine i just you know i i'm tired at the
end of the day it's a lot you know uh
house of gucci i did see that and i
actually thought it was pretty decent i
saw it a couple weeks ago it's pretty
decent you know i don't really like that
gaga but it was pretty decent and don't
look up which was just like climate
change propaganda and it was sort of
okay and not quite horrible and whatever
it's all right i saw two i saw two or
three out of the six or whatever it was
um anyway the machinery is dying the
hollywood machinery but it always needs
you to look at a bright shiny thing and
they just showed us the brightest
shiniest thing the fresh prince of bel
air just smacked the zebra from
madagascar and now everybody's talking
about it including me and this is on the
very same weekend that joe biden the man
pretending to be president of the united
states was in poland and went off the
remarks and said that basically we need
regime change in russia the same guy
telling us we're not going to world war
three sort of makes you wonder so now i
want to show you a selection of uh
tweets
several of them deleted by democrats and
lefty politicians about what happened
because you know we've been told for a
while that words are violence so if you
believe that words are violence then i
guess violence is violence in in the
name of words this is this is a real
problem here's ayanna presley she's a
congresswoman she is a member of the
squad
she happens to have alopecia she says
alopecia nations stand up thank you will
smith
shout out to all the husbands who defend
their wives living with alopecia in the
face of daily ignorance and insults
oscars women with baldies are for real
men only wait what women with baldies
are for real men only boys boys need not
apply and there she is and and she's got
the the shaved head too so
she deleted that tweet because basically
she's saying yeah you're allowed to
punch people people are allowed to uh
make jokes and your response should be
that you hit people again this should
not surprise us these are the words are
violence
people okay these are the same people
that say if you say something we're
allowed to burn down a building or break
a window et cetera et cetera now i want
to talk about alopecia for a minute
because many of you know this i wrote
about it in my first book don't burn
this book um i suffered from alopecia
about five years ago for about two years
and it was quite horrific uh conor can
you throw up so the image that i'm
showing you on the left it was
significantly worse than this i don't
know where all the images are and i
didn't really feel like looking for them
because it was pretty bad but this was
sort of halfway through when actually
some of my hair was growing back and it
started with uh you know sort of quarter
size or dime sized little spots losing
hair all the time it moved up really to
the front of my head and everything else
the picture you're seeing on the right
uh that's from a couple months back when
my hair was was fully back
you know alopecia it's an autoimmune
disease and they don't know exactly what
causes it i went for all the blood tests
and all the other stuff and i was fine
they so they chalk it up to stress
usually and interestingly when i
developed alopecia um it was right when
i started talking about what was wrong
with the left when i still consider
myself a lefty and i was just getting
unending hate online people saying the
worst
most awful things and it was the first
time in my life i was ever dealing with
that and i guess i wasn't dealing with
the stress
properly
and i was just losing chunks and chunks
of hair this is all my hair uh i
mentioned in the book how how i dealt
with it i changed my diet a lot got rid
of a lot of sugar got rid of a lot of
carbs um i did prp which is
platelet-rich plasma they take your
blood they literally take your blood
flow arm they spin it in the centrifuge
they get the plasma from your blood and
they inject it into your head and it
gets your cells going it's rather
extraordinary people do it for all
all sorts of things i've done it for my
knee as well um anyway the point is
whether you have alopecia or not i am
not allowed to punch people who make fun
of
me when i had bald spots in the back of
my head and i was using paint i mean i
was literally doing my show and i would
use like goo paint and spray on stuff
and powders to do that i couldn't just
punch somebody who was mean to me but
this is what
many people on the modern left believe
uh here's another representative
congressman jamal bowman here's what he
said teachable moment don't joke about a
black woman's hair and then of course he
deleted that as well um
no you're allowed to joke about people
and then people are allowed to make fun
of you they're allowed to not associate
with you
they're allowed to mock you
and all of those things they're not
allowed to physically assault you
this is what laws are we have freedom of
speech and if someone says something
mean to you you can ignore them or you
can say something mean to them
but you can't attack them uh here's a
tweet from a university of florida
professor his name's michael mcdonald he
said will smith just showed ted cruz
what a real man does when somebo someone
belittles their wife so again violence
is okay when you're offended this should
not i think you see what i'm doing here
everything that that these last you know
five or six years have has been about
has led us to this that it will be okay
to just assault people now interestingly
and this is a sort of sidebar and i did
not know this uh but several people have
mentioned it and my guys mentioned it
this morning will smith happens to be in
an open marriage now you can judge that
or not judge that if if they're fully
happy in their marriage and they feel
fully actualized and they're both having
sex with other people i don't know
exactly what that means or do they bring
other people in the bedroom or anything
else but basically you can bang will
smith's wife but you can't make a joke
about her that seems to be where we're
roughly at in this thing uh well then
it's been interesting watching the way
the media of course has covered this uh
here's a reporter named sarah fisher i
think she's from axios and watch the way
she plays these games around what should
happen related to free speech and comedy
and jokes
what happened last night at the oscars
was so dramatic so unexpected that i
think viewers at home were confused
about how they should think about it
people in the room were confused about
how they should think about it and it's
actually sparked a huge conversation
about the future of jokes and speech not
just at award shows but at comedy clubs
you know do people have the right to go
up and slap someone for a joke they
don't like obviously the answer is no
but because the academy didn't do
anything with will smith in real time
they let him sit there they let him
accept his award and deliver a speech
it's now become a debate online
ah it's become a debate online and we're
having a conversation about jokes and
speech here let me end the conversation
you cannot physically violently assault
people for jokes and or speech i think i
did that right that's how it works by
the way i'm going on tour did you know
that daverubin.com
events uh you can't hit me i might say
some things that might offend you i make
fun of all sorts of people and things
and happenings in the world you cannot
hit me or throw things at me what you
can do after if you get a vip ticket is
you can take a selfie with me you can
hug me for a second one second you know
my policy just a one second hug a two
second too much
but this is a major
escalation and this is sort of what they
want they want us all to be afraid to be
together to be around each other to to
take jokes in and understand we're all
part of it now look i don't love the
idea like trust me trust me trust me
trust me when i had alopecia it was
horrible it really was horrible i
thought about quitting i really did
there was a moment where i was gonna
quit this whole freaking thing almost
before it had even began um it was
really it was depressing um you know
it's horrible when you look in the
mirror and you don't see the person that
you want to see right
like that's just how it is um but you
know there are there are fat people out
there and you're allowed to make fun of
fat people and you're allowed to you're
allowed to make jokes period but what
they just did what the system just did
was sort of signal out to all of the
remaining people who speak freely at
some level and this is this falls on the
lapse of comedians which is what chris
rock is and he's a great comedian by the
way and he took it like a champ whether
that whole thing was faked or not i mean
he took it like a champ
and he continued right the show must go
on um
the point is you cannot
allow a situation where now comedians
are going to be on stage going oh [ __ ]
did i just say that joke and some guy in
the crowd you know if a comedian makes a
fat joke and some guy in the crowd is
sitting next to his fat girlfriend that
the guy feels like he can just jump on
stage and punch the comedian it will
further degrade our already broken
ability to be together and to
to laugh together which is the most
important thing it's the most healing
thing we got you know i often talk about
don rickles remember don rickles when
this show is over go on the youtube and
and watch some old don rickles stand up
making fun of everybody jews and blacks
and gays and asians and this and that
and it made everybody in the room part
of it everyone felt oh i'm part of
america because you can you can make fun
of a silly stereotype and that is not
the the totality of me but what the left
has done with these collectivist ideas
they think that that you you're gay
you're black
that that is the sum totality of you and
it's and it's wrong and it's going to
break us all it is going to break us all
and if you don't believe it watch how
then throughout the oscars it continued
their intersectional
road to hell continued here are uh
comedians amy schumer and wanda sykes
along with actress regina hall i don't
have to put i think she's an actress i
don't have to put quotes around it but i
will put quotes around amy schumer uh
comedian and wanda sykes comedian uh
making fun of florida over the don't say
gay bill we're gonna have a great night
uh tonight and for you people in florida
we're gonna have a gay night
the only one who i half respect there is
john travolta who didn't laugh at the
joke and isn't he gay or he's half gay
or something i'm not outing john
travolta i don't know does or he goes
and gets massages from people i don't
know what he's doing but he just he's
like oh you [ __ ] people but they're
oh my god they said the thing and it's
not based in reality and
meanwhile they're all sitting in that
room by the way
and nobody's wearing a mask again i saw
pictures on the red carpet and stuff the
staffs are still wearing masks the
photographers the people that serve them
still wearing masks
but let's just put that aside let's also
put aside the fact that there is no such
thing as a don't say gay bill there is a
bill that is related to transparency in
school so why don't we just unpack that
because while these people live in their
faux reality while they make a [ __ ] ton
of money to judge you and then you pay
to have them judge you with their crappy
movies there are a couple people out
there who are fighting this endless
[ __ ] there happens to be this guy
what's his name over here in florida
he's doing a pretty good job and then
you had this governor's race in virginia
where you had the losing candidates say
parents that he said parents should not
be involved in what is taught in the
school system and so
there is a debate in this country
about what role parents have in the
education of their kids and i think in
florida with our parents bill of rights
with the bill we're going to sign here
today which bill other bills we're going
to sign later
we believe
parents not only have a role they have a
fundamental role to be involved in the
education of their kids all right so you
get it you get how hollywood works this
is what they do this is a bunch of lefty
rich elitists who are trying to push all
of their views which actually have
nothing to do with reality because as
you know the word gay is not in the bill
okay and this has this is about
kindergartners through third graders
not talking about gender identity and
sexuality with state employees and then
allowing the state employees to hide
that from the parents but these people
just sit there and they applaud them oh
my god we love gays so much it's
actually offensive to actual gays that
just want to function in the world
morons uh well desantis is continuing to
go on so he's he's not
given up on that he's pushing back on
that he's also going to ban porn in
schools i did not know that porn was in
schools
i'm old school born in 76 i was in grade
school in the early 80s we didn't have
um we didn't have porn in school i'm
trying to remember we watched i remember
there was a week where in social studies
we watched a show called the voyage of
the mimi did you guys see that it's like
about a bunch of people they go whale
hunting i think in alaska it's pretty
good one of the people gets hypothermia
it's a whole situation that's what we
watched when i was a kid apparently
there's porn in schools now well not
here in florida unfortunately we've seen
some uh some books in some of these
libraries i mean you're talking about
kids in middle school some of the stuff
that has ended up there
incredibly
incredibly disturbing stuff
you have some groups that want to take
away
classic books like to kill a mockingbird
but they want things like gender queer a
memoir which is a cartoon style book
with graphic images of children
performing sexual acts that is wrong
that has no place in the schools they
want to eliminate of mice and men
but lawn boy a book containing explicit
passages of pedophilia is somehow
accepted as being okay parents want
education for their kids they're not
interested in indoctrination
through the school system and that's
where
[Applause]
education not indoctrination hollywood
wants to indoctrinate and they do it
through the system it just is it's a
it's sort of a depressing reality
because there's a lot of good stuff that
used to come out of hollywood we all
have movies we love and and shows we
love whether it's game of thrones or
sopranos or total recall or interstellar
or whatever the hell you used to love
star wars is a great example of it
because star wars when george lucas was
originally creating it was creating this
anti-establishment thing he fought the
studios that's actually the backstory of
star wars and then he was as an
individual created this incredible story
that captured the imagination of
generations of people generations of
people and then ultimately he sold the
company and i don't begrudge him for
selling the company and he was you know
the fans had sort of turned him against
him after the prequels which is very
unfortunate because the prequels are
actually pretty good
um but he sold it to the giant
corporation that exists on earth disney
and then disney completely destroyed
star wars and then they push all of this
nonsense messaging so what is it that
hollywood is protesting
when amy schumer is up there dancing gay
gay gay it's like amy schumer what are
you really saying is it very very
important to you that a first grader is
taught that just because they have a
penis it doesn't mean they're a boy and
that the teacher should hide that from
the parent is that really what you what
you're saying and all these idiots
laughing there except again for john
travolta but he's not gay he's not gay i
i don't i'm not not that there's
anything wrong with that
you know
i don't think there's anything wrong
with that uh
yeah ridiculous
um
but let's continue let's get oh what was
voyage of the meme about you guys got me
some information voyage of the mimi
which was a show that i watched in
school i think i was in fifth grade was
about taking a census of humpback whales
it was a five episode series if i'm not
mistaken it was it was quite good we
didn't have porn back then that's what
we had
we've got a little bit more of what the
disney ceo is protesting
if you look at what the ncaa has done
by allowing
basically men to compete in women's
athletics in this case the swimming the
ncaa
uh is basically taking efforts to
destroy women's athletics they're trying
to undermine the integrity of the
competition and they're crowning
somebody else uh the woman's champion
and we think that's wrong and so in
florida i'm going to be uh later today
because this is a floridian who i think
deserves to be recognized you know we're
going to be doing a proclamation uh
saying
that emma
is the best female swimmer in the 500
meter freestyle because she earned that
and we need to stop allowing
organizations like the ncaa to
perpetuate frauds on the public
okay so while hollywood cheers you know
first graders learning about gender
identity and males biological males
beating women in swimming florida's
fighting against that now we found this
clip and this is going to blow your mind
okay
you may remember a a guy by the name of
david letterman he was a late night host
for about 30 years he used to make jokes
about all sorts of stuff and he'd make
fun of all sorts of people and i loved
love love david letterman and i wish i
know he's got some interview show now
but i wish that show continued nobody
really watches late night shows anymore
but we needed somebody that was not
purely political right you didn't know
his politics it was a little more like
johnny carson you didn't know exactly
what he thought he kind of made fun of
everybody well he had a couple years ago
he had this woman on and her name is
serena williams and serena williams is
the best female tennis player on earth
in the history of the world she's the
best ain't no doubt about it well she
went on letterman's show a couple years
ago and you're not going to believe this
the bigot that she is she said there's
biological differences between men and
women
well
actually it's funny because andy murray
he all he was been joking about um
myself and him playing a match and i'm
like andy seriously like are you kidding
me because for me tennis in men's tennis
and women's centers are completely
almost two separate sports so i'm like
if i were to play andy murray i would
lose 606 0 in
5 to 6 minutes maybe 10 minutes because
no it's true it's a completely
it's a completely different word the men
are a lot faster and me and they they
get they serve harder they hit hard it's
just a different game and i love to play
women's students and i i only want to
play girls because i don't want to be
embarrassed i would not do the tour i
wouldn't do billie jean any justice so
andy stop it we're not i'm not gonna let
you kill me i'm with you when it comes
to tennis i only wanna play girls
letterman making a joke about how he
wants to play against girls in tennis
to a girl tennis player
i mean really think about that right now
did you guys know this right at this
very moment tucker carlson who has the
highest rated show in the history of
cable news he has been banned from
twitter for the last six days or so
because he made a point saying that leah
thomas the the swimmer the biologically
male swimmer who's winning all the
female tournaments uh basically
shouldn't be winning all the female
tournaments he's now been banned from
twitter highest rated cable news host in
the history of television he's gone from
twitter for basically just saying
exactly what serena williams female
tennis star serena williams is saying
right there men are stronger they hit
the ball harder as a general rule they
surf faster not only that she's saying
they're completely different sports
they're completely different sports and
that andy murray would beat her
basically 606 0 in a couple minutes is
that because she's a bigot is that
because serena williams is self-hating
or hates women or something like that do
you think that's what it is but now
let's continue because i showed you
david letterman
late night former late night host david
letterman who was a part of the
hollywood machine but letterman was
always sort of outside of the hollywood
machine at the same time you want to see
a great movie about that watch the late
shift it was an hbo movie about the
fight between jay leno and david
letterman uh when johnny carson was was
stepping down and how nbc basically
mucked up the whole thing uh but now i
want to shift to another late night host
who i've really been working on so you
already know who i'm talking about i
want to talk about bill maher for just a
second because bill maher's show on
friday he did it again every time i i
give this guy credit and by the way
producers of bill maher show i know
you're watching as always um i give this
guy credit when he gets it right on
wokism and crt and everything he doesn't
vote the right way okay i'm not sure
what makes him a liberal in a modern
sense anymore
but here he is just going right back
into the republicans or racists okay
well um we have the first black woman
let's go back if for some of the people
who don't remember this also the first
black we ever had we've only had two
thurgood marshall 1967. when he died
uh
it was george bush the first was
president
and so they accepted the idea that there
was now a black seat on the court and
that's how we got clarence thomas now i
thought it was
not exactly cricket to give the black
seat to someone who didn't represent the
majority of black thinking in america
but here's the difference at least they
accepted george bush did the idea of we
at least one black seat on the court
right i think today's republicans would
not do that i think they would be
thrilled to have no black seats on the
court okay a lot of them okay so judging
judging by yeah because you by the way
they treated this nominee right which
one exactly which was racist top to
bottom
right i don't know who that loser is at
the end there was nothing racist in the
hearings to katanji brown jackson there
was absolutely nothing racist asking
someone if they know what a woman is is
not racist she's going to be confirmed
either way no one said oh you're black
you can't you can't be a judge that
would be racist okay so that guy's just
a clown forget that as for bill maher i
don't know what to do with this guy
anymore like this is all you got it's
all you got left is my political
opponents are racist it's very
unfortunate right it's unfortunate that
someone could get so far in their
thinking really understand
the the right side of things in so many
ways critical race theory and wokism and
even the covid stuff and all that you
sure you were wrong and wrong and wrong
for years but then you come around okay
better late than never fine and we wanna
we wanna welcome people to the same side
with open arms but still the implication
that
the supreme court justice nominee that
the hearings had anything to do with
racism the idea that there should be a
black seat
in 2022 america that there should be a
black do we have a um an
italian-american seat is there is there
a seat for tony soprano is there a seat
for asian americans is there a seat for
native americans is there a seat for
pansexual two-spirit americans is there
a seat for jewish americans is there a
seat for muslim americans this is
complete
neo-racist nonsense so you rail against
woke-ism you rail against equity but you
want equity apparently or you realize
that you're just getting too damn close
to the truth and i think that's probably
what it is
you're too damn close to what the truth
is so at the end it's uh but the
republicans still are all racist you
think ted cruz's questioning
of katanji brown jackson was racist and
also he said something that was really
really awful there that um the majority
of black thinking that these meaning
clarence thomas doesn't represent the
majority of black thinking
i did not know
that um black people think a certain way
i thought the black people are
individual people who could think all
sorts of different ways i don't know if
you were to poll all black people that
they would agree on something and just
because in a majority
think something that doesn't mean it's
right have you ever heard of the term
the tyranny of the majority so the
majority of black thinking meaning we
should hold a seat for black people
and then we should install people who
just think the way we sort of think that
the majority of black people think and
that would be the not racist thing to do
do you understand why this is so [ __ ]
backwards
bill i don't know what to do i don't
know what to do i think i'm on your
podcast in a couple weeks and i look
forward to talking about it so this is
not an attack on you but what i don't
get it man i don't get it at this point
and that other guy i mean just just an
epic clown all they have is racism all
they have is racism and we have to
realize that it doesn't work you don't
want the majority of the tyranny that's
the point i go into that in my book by
the way
in case
in case you're interested uh we've got a
epic an epic cold close for you today uh
so i do want you to hang on for just a
couple of minutes before i get to that
though
um i do want to mention spider-man i
mentioned it up top because i watched it
this weekend and then it and then this
whole oscars thing happened and it
really made me think you know
when uh when avengers end game remember
that when that one came out it was sort
of like the end it seemingly felt like
the end of all the superhero movies man
they've done everything with every
freaking superhero every story every
everything and i remember when i walked
out of the movie theater i tweeted
something like you know the movie was
just fine but we need new stories we
need new stories not retreads
of comic books that were written by
people in the 1940s and i mean that with
all due respect to stan lee one of the
greatest most innovative geniuses true
genius like who captured talk about
capturing an imagination that george
lucas did i mean think about the the
thousands of characters basically and
worlds that that stan lee created but
all we're doing is just remaking
remaking remaking remaking and not only
that then i watched this new spider-man
and spoiler alert it came out months ago
so if you have to pause this or mute it
fine it's like now we bring back all of
these old movies we make all of the bad
guys now they're good guys oh there's
tobey maguire i remember that we're in
the member very member berry version
of our culture right now member berry if
you watched south park you know what i'm
talking about that all we seemingly can
do are remember things that remind us of
some other time before instead of really
thinking about what's going on right now
so my question to you people on this
good day
is what are you watching or reading or
listening to that is new i mean really
new new characters new ideas not just
retreads of old things it's all
hollywood can give us does it surprise
you that the clowns who are up there
dancing gay gay gay and clapping to this
nonsense and punching people over jokes
does it surprise you that they have a
complete inability to to provide
anything that is new or interesting or
innovative
of course it doesn't because they're at
the end of it they're at the end
of
the goodness of freedom they're they're
there and now they're
bickering over nothing there's nothing
left so now they're trying to destroy
the whole damn thing so i want to find
some new things and i want to amplify
voices of people that are thinking about
things in a new way whether it's
cryptocurrency or movies
or a new way to make hot dogs people
less boot and raccoon meat you know like
something something new we need
something new and these people can't
give it to us whether they're faking the
whole thing or whether they're just
eating themselves alive there's just
nothing
left there absolutely nothing left uh
got a couple comments from
reubenreport.locals.com
zionist says good evening two big
terrorist hat uh i'm going into joke
mode that this one looks seems somewhat
serious good evening two big terrorist
attacks in israel in the last couple
days so will slip will smith slapping
that other guy i don't give a [ __ ] yeah
so then there you know what's
interesting about israel right now is
there was this huge peace summit this
past weekend because that orange man
remember the orange guy
he caused uh through jared kushner and
avi berkowitz and a couple other people
that israel signed like something like
six peace deals with its neighbors we
don't talk about it anymore but they had
a they had a summit in israel like they
had the arab countries bringing and some
of these african countries bringing
their leaders to israel we didn't really
talk about that much today i guess we
should have done that maybe i'll do some
more on that tomorrow but then there was
a terrorist attack in the midst of that
um
kanto says i didn't even know the oscars
were on until the incident happened they
need ratings yeah i didn't know either i
didn't know either um we were what were
we doing we were actually we made a duck
last night we made a delicious duck if
you want to we smoked a duck a whole
duck it was awesome and if you want to
see a picture of the duck you can see it
at our locals community uh juliana says
well it's a good thing chris rock didn't
make a joke about alec baldwin's wife
yes that damn why didn't i think of that
joke before that's good that's good
because he would have shot her i see
what you did there that's
that's good that's good guys it's me
monday over at the reuben report locals
community here's uh the meme that i
threw up this morning
beautiful beautiful like look at those
two elderly women up there that was what
my teachers used to look like right like
think about your your grade school
teachers i hope everyone had a good
recess it's time for math teachers now
whiteness is a privilege now who's ready
to hear about my sexuality
i've enjoyed this monday show i hope you
have too we got a great cold clothes for
you just a reminder real quick guys uh
don't burn this country's out on april
12th you can get your copy at
davereuben.com
book and the tour is coming tickets are
selling fast uh we've got all kinds of
great guests like benny johnson don
junior andrew clavin michael males janmi
park glenn back megan mccain megan kelly
blake masters
dennis prager who's coming here for
dinner tonight larry elder and others
you can get tickets at daverubin.com
events my full interview with judge
andrew napolitano is up right now on all
platforms and uh that's all i've got to
say
about that
this is the last time i'm hosting these
awards so
i don't care anymore um i'm joking i
never did um
nbc clearly don't care either fifth time
so i mean kevin hart was fired from the
oscars because of some offensive tweets
hello
lucky for me the hollywood foreign press
can barely speak english
and
they've no idea what twitter is so
i got offered this gig by fax so let's
go out with a bang
let's have a laugh at your expense shall
we remember they're just jokes we're all
going to die soon and there's no sequel
so
look
talking of all you perverts it was a big
year
it was a big year for pedophile movies
um
surviving r kelly
leaving neverland
two popes
shut up shut up i don't care i don't
care
many talented people of color were
snubbed in major categories um
unfortunately there's nothing we can do
about that the hollywood foreign press
are all very very racist so
fifth time so
we were gonna do an in memoriam this
year but when i saw the list of people
that had died it wasn't diverse enough
it just no
it was mostly white people and i thought
nah not on my watch
we gotta drag it out for three hours you
could binge watch the entire first
season of afterlife instead of watching
this show that that's a show about a man
who wants to kill himself because his
wife dies of cancer and it's still more
fun than this okay
spoiler alert um season two is on the
way so in the end he obviously didn't
kill himself just like jeffrey epstein
shut up i know he's your friend but i
don't care
once upon a time in hollywood nearly
three hours long leonardo dicaprio
attended the premiere and by the end his
date was too old for him
even prince andrews like come on leo
mate you know
you're nearly 50 son um
the world got to see james corden as a
fat [ __ ]
he was also in the movie cats but
no one saw that um and the reviews are
shocking i saw one that said this is the
worst thing to happen to cats since dogs
right
but dame judy dench defended the film
saying it was the role she was born to
play because she
i can't do this next joke
because she loves nothing better than
plonking herself down on the carpet
lifting her leg and licking her
[Applause]
she's old school um
apple roared into the tv game with a
morning show a superb drama yeah
[Applause]
a superb drama about the importance of
dignity and doing the right thing made
by a company that runs sweatshops in
china so well you say you woke but the
companies you work for i mean
unbelievable apple amazon disney if isis
started a streaming service you'd call
your agent wouldn't you so
if you do win an award tonight
pl don't use it as a platform to make a
political speech right you're in no
position to lecture the public about
anything you know nothing about the real
world most of you spent less time in
school than greta thundberg so if you
win right
come up accept your little award thank
your agent and your god
[Applause]